I remember a couple years ago looking at
psychological studies specifically when
it came to radical jihadists and a lot
of psychologists found that it was
poverty and polyamory that led to of
course people becoming radicalists
because there there wasn't enough women
for the guys to go around one guy would
marry 10 to 12 to 15 to 20 wives and
there wasn't enough wives to go around
because of the poverty because of the
lack of Education a lot of people just
you know went to extremist groups so
when you look at those conditions when
you look at what's happening in in
today's day and age in the dating world
when you look at what's happening
financially with the banks and the big
multinational corporations pretty much
stealing everyone's money we're pretty
much creating the same situation for
radicalization so uh yes the things are
not going to be good with so many people
radicalized with so many people going to
the fringes and going to these extremist
groups that they're going to be taking
advantage of with